the next day and I'm heading out of
Penang with my head full of authentic
Malaysian dishes from last night
it's a great shame that we don't know
the dishes better back home in England
think of any other international cuisine
and you could name you know specialities
but when Malaysian cooking it's almost
like a hidden agenda foods exciting I
mean there's no two ways about that but
it's quite complex I'm keen to get on
now and search even further
I'm flying 300 kilometres south to kuala
lumper or KL to the locals
[Music]
it's the capital city and it's where
I'll find some of the most adventurous
Malaysian cooking in the country
[Music]
but I'm not relying on the food critics
to show me where to go
I've arranged to meet Malaysia's answer
to the hairy biker's money proper
motorbikes I've got a Harley home here
yes I'm not and I'd run yeah love it
weekends absolutely perfect how are you
good I'm DC DC good to see so did you
build this one I'm ready for a
competition a couple of years ago as it
shows oh yes it is fantastic so good to
see a glamorous chick on a bike as much
as we love bikes we look for food all
the time so we left food and bite is
something we call right to eat and
foodie Hells Angels amazing after you
thank you the bikers are taking me on
the trail of their favorite foodie pit
stops and inside the market there is a
legendary dish that Mila wants me to try
torpedo suit yeah so what is it oh they
say it's actually soup especially for
men and this is how it looks like is the
part of the cow what the [ __ ] is that
the both mainly with stuff a point penis
yeah this is what's up top we do is all
about yeah
penis ooh this is a bit of a chef's
dream come true no I don't love it I'm
gonna think of every goddamn [ __ ]
food critic in the country and sort of
do to them what they've been doing to me
for the last 10 years yeah screw them so
take this off here yeah be gentle be
gentle yeah hey Gill Michael Winner
Giles Coren so small right yeah yeah
Matthew Norman yeah it's been a long
time trust me
Matthew Norman almost men wouldn't eat
this thinking that that's gonna make
their widget grow bigger apparently it's
not just the size it's just
stronger last longer there's a reason
why they come here penis in the bowl yep
few little extra bits for you Mina
Amelia's favorite soup is flavored with
spices like clothes and cinema but
there's no getting away from the main
ingredient here goes here we go check on
the skin yet right to eat let's go
thanks buddy
Mira come on
the soups nice but it's the kanji bit in
the middle like gristle now I'm crossing
my laces I'm like crazy between my ball
bag of my my ball penis because I'm like
yeah muscly grizzly and a chewy almost
like sort of an oxtail but with a soft
bone inside not good and the size of
them Jesus Christ